reduce energy consumption and expand the use of climate-friendly electric
vehicles. Visit redwoodenergy.org for complete details or call 707-269-1700
for more information. It is seven o'clock. This is Redwood Community Radio,
KMUD Garberville, KMUE Eureka KLA Laytonville, where the views and opinions
expressed throughout the broadcast day are those of the speakers and not
necessarily those of the station staff or underwriters. Time will be made
available for all sorts of information and I'm going to start this music here
and deal with stuff and then it's time for Ask Your Herb Doctor.
[Music]
And I believe we'll be hearing Dr. Murray and Dr. Murray's. Whoops, there we go.
Do I have both of you here? Yes, you have me.
I don't hear Andrew.
Hey Andrew, could you speak up for a second? Well we can't hear you so you're
just gonna have to switch to this other microphone. I apologize, we're gonna go
back to the music for just one second then we'll be back.
[Music]
Hopefully Sarah, you're there with me. Yes, I'm here. Welcome to your Ask Your Herb
Doctor. It's October the 15th 2021, the colors were starting to look really nice
on the way into the studio this evening so next month it'll be too dark probably
the usual time to come in but some beautiful autumn colors starting to come
in now so it's so nice to see this transition and hopefully we'll be getting
some more rain. Anyway this is KMUD 91.1 FM and from 7.30 until the end of the
show callers are invited to call in with any questions related to this month's
subject amongst other things of the treatment approach to cancer and some
mythology surrounding cancer and once again very pleased to invite and have on
the show Dr. Raymond Peat with his 40 plus years of experience and ongoing
research bearing out the effectiveness of his treatment strategies or his
approaches to treatment which are not orthodox and even sometimes are not even
alternative as we will find out so a little more than that so Dr. Peat are you
with us? Yes. Okay well thanks so much for joining again perhaps as always for
those people who perhaps might have never heard of you before and we'll give
out your contact details at the end of the show here would you just introduce
yourself in terms of your academic and professional background? My first working
experience was in actually teaching biology was one of my first courses but I
was meanwhile studying literature and linguistics and I about ten years later
I decided to go back to graduate school in biology and studied the effects of
aging on metabolism energy metabolism in particular and I was right from the
start of my graduate work I was interested in
Varberg's approach to the energy metabolism he saw the failure in the
energy system as the essential cause of cancer but I think that people right
from that period when he was very unpopular academically because he
believed cancer was not a genetic disease but a metabolic disease a few
people who accepted that idea of metabolic disease misinterpreted
Varberg. Varberg's basic idea was that there's something about cancer cells
that doesn't allow them to rest and accumulate ATP to do their normal work
and so they just keep running can turn off the expenditure of energy and that's
what leads to the association with excess lactate formation even in the
presence of oxygen. Okay so from the perspective of one of the main questions
I wanted to bring out tonight and and this is not as a condemnation but we
hear it often and when we were graduates of the school of herbal medicine in
England when we did our degree in herbal medicine and from then until now there's
this current this counter current well counter current against your way of
thinking and certainly our way of thinking at this point having worked
with you for the last 11 years or so but the belief that sugar is bad for you I
wanted us first to explore that and so for people that are listening the number
if you're you'd like to call in from 7 30 on to join the show either questions
about cancer or Covid or any other subject that you have the number 707 923
3911 so just put that out there once again from 7 30 to 8 o'clock callers are
invited to call in 707 923 3911. So Dr. Peatare the main the main tenet that I
hear time and time again on which we were actually taught the same kind of
thing and it's erroneous and you're the you're the one to explain it I know
you've told us and over and over and we repeat this to other people so not to
say that we are into the mistaken belief that sugar feeds cancer but I was
listening to a podcast a very a very good podcast I won't start naming names or
anything like that because I don't want to insinuate the person as being yeah
unknowledgeable about the subject in any way because she was very very detailed
but basically she was giving a cancer dialogue an hour and a half which is a
qualified medical herbalist and she runs a cancer clinic and she's quite well
involved in the treatment of cancer alternatively but again she said the
same thing and I just want to just read this back to you I kind of transcribed
it word-for-word so it's not plagiarism as such but I just want to read back to
you what she has said and they're so often repeated in the alternative
circles and in mainstream that sugars bad unit causes cancer or can feed
cancer so let me just read this to you Dr. Peatand if you can listen to the
paragraph and then give us your rendition of why actually sugars not bad
for you and why you don't want to starve yourself of sugar so she said to avoid
sugar cancer does not like sugar to run its oxidative pathways through
glycolysis and it does make its energy that way using a lot of sugar so we can
starve it that way into submission by stringently avoiding sugar and sugary
foods and that will help to get the mitochondria away from simply
glycolysis but actually starting to use fats and proteins for energy as well and
cancer can do that too but not an efficiently or effectively as healthy
cells so by avoiding sugar you're going to turn up the Krebs cycle in healthy
cells and you're going to direct energy that way away from the cancer cells and
also decrease lactic acid around the cancer and that will set it back so your
impression of sugars being put into the Krebs cycle for production of ATP and how
cancer does definitely seem to be a lactic acid producing issue and you've
always been warning about lactic acid and seeing it as a cancer promoter but
in terms of sugars metabolism in the body why would you not want to decrease
someone's sugars and actually put them on a non-sugar diet in the last five or
ten years there have been several publications that clearly show that if
you starve a cancerous animal or patient for glucose you can tend to put it into
ketosis and anything you do to it to put it into ketosis like starving it for a
day or so or giving it stress hormones that mobilize fat out of storage so that
it tends to push fat metabolism rather than glucose metabolism all of these
things increase the growth of cancer the rate of growth and probably the
mechanism for most of that increase of cancer proliferation and growth is that
stress whether it's hypoglycemia or hypoxia activates the protein called the
hypoxia but it's initiated by glycolysis or stress just as much as hypoxia and
that HIF activates among other things the mast cells to produce histamine and
several other pro-inflammatory interleukin 6 I think is one of
dozens and dozens of pro-inflammatory things all of which increase
inflammation and so HIF is a promoter of both inflammation and carcinogenesis or
cancer growth and so the in the last 10 years or so the physiological chemistry
of it has been worked out with experiments and this line of criticizing
the cancer dependency on glucose goes back mostly I think through a book in
the 1970s by Chappote and Blinoff they published many articles but summed up
through work in a book and they showed that the presence of a tumor is eating
all of the available glucose and that in response to prevent hypoglycemia the
glucocorticoids are activated and produce in defense produce a tendency
towards hyperglycemia a diabetes type of metabolism and among other things showed
that starving the animal was the worst thing for the outcome of the tumor that
maintaining the animals weight by giving it extra food in particular extra
carbohydrate to satisfy the tumors appetite for glucose because they showed
that if you don't do that cortisol rises to maintain not just normal but even
elevated glucose in the blood and the way the cortisol does that and this is
what happens during fasting or producing a ketogenic condition by cutting
carbohydrates the cortisol produces sugar to satisfy the tumor appetite for
it by breaking down proteins and the glutamine is very easily entered into
the glycolysis pathways that sort of it's turned into glucose to feed the
lactic acid metabolism that means that when you're starving for glucose your
cortisol rises to eat up your body proteins to make sugar and so it
accelerates the cachexia of the tumor condition and accelerates degeneration
and death so basically when you're low oxygen or low sugar you're going to
stimulate a lot of pro-cancer inflammatory mediators like you were
mentioning the atoxia protein HIF which then trigger mast cells the histamine
and all sorts of inflammatory mediators interleukin 6 and those are all
associated with cancer tumor growth correct yeah it's basically a stress
metabolism brought on by the the fact that there's something wrong with the
tumor cell preventing it from getting into the relaxed turned-off condition
that allows it to store ATP it's as if it's being prodded constantly estrogen
is one of the things that crowds the metabolism in the direction of glycolysis
so if you were going to starve yourself of sugar you're saying that you was
going to drive more fats into the system to create energy therefore producing
lactic acid but the tumor cells themselves would want to be
preferentially driven by glucose no although they do love fatty acids
their mitochondria aren't dead they're able to use as much fat as is available
as well as glucose so that the you can't start them even if your cortisol was
turned off so it couldn't break down your body protein it would the cancer
would still adapt them be very vigorous on the fat diet okay so and key key
tones are a good energy that's been one of the points the ketogenic people have
said that ketones are too hard for cancer cells to digest but in fact
experimenters have fed cancer-bearing animals with ketones so they don't have
to go through this stress condition of being starved just adding ketones to
their diet feeds the tumor okay so they're the cancer cell basically to
sum up the life cycle of it in terms of its fuel hungry needs it'll either
derive what it needs from glucose or it'll derive what it needs from the
lactic acid cycle that is the energy wasteful side of metabolism so if you
were going to become keto a ketotic and follow a ketotic diet and get into
ketosis as some way of supposedly avoiding the sugar issues that will
raise your HIF and the stress hormones and the inflammation histamine and the
others so which all promotes cancer growth so it's either way you either if
you starve yourself a sugar you're gonna raise those HIF proteins and increase
the inflammation or and or you're going to increase your cortisol which is going
to feed cancer yeah so the solution is to find out what causes that
inflammation that keeps cancer cells from relaxing in the normal energy
production and use and obviously I think the other thing that goes goes without
without saying yeah really is that if you're going to starve yourself sugar as
far as not just cancer cells we're talking about that perhaps may
preferentially want to consume sugar for the angiogenesis production of new
capillaries their blood vessels supply etc etc and their rapid growth rate but
everything else in your body needs sugar and I think this is the being the
rationale behind what you've always said about not starving yourself for sugar and
how how essential sugar is for your metabolism not just for your brain which
consumes most of it but for everything that happens in the body the energy
currency the ATP you know the blood vessels themselves need a sugar diet
right well isn't it true that every cell in the body needs glucose to operate
properly Dr. Peat yeah the absence always ends up creating inflammation and then
if you if you don't eat sugar then your body will break down your own body's
tissues taken to utilize and release the sugar so either way your cells are going
to use sugar it's either you feed it to them or you end up breaking yourself
down and producing media's yeah the same as playing along famous claimed another
immune tissues are the first to go under glucose deprivation and then your skin
and muscles are the bulk of the source of glucose okay so you'll break down
your muscle bulk mm-hmm so rather than barking up the wrong tree and pointing
the finger blame it sugar as driving cancer rather supply a healthy quantity
of sugar whether it's sucrose or fructose or glucose to keep all your cells fueled
as it were and so you don't go into the stress metabolism side of physiology
which will derange you further and this is a little bit similar to the candida
hypothesis where people also say the same mantra that sugar feeds candida and
I think what you've said in the past is that the yeast penetration into the
tissues just goes further in the absence of sugar trying to get more sugar from
tissues that it's not currently involved with yeah hungry yeast cells become
aggressive and mean and will eat go anywhere looking for sugar yeah okay so
you're listening to ask Europe Dr. K.M.U.D. Garberful 91.1 FM from 730 to the
end of the show you invited to call in the questions and number here if you'd
like to call in is 707 923 3911 707 923 3911 so Dr. Peat to get onto a
continuation of the alternative and holistic approach to cancer I think we
covered the first instance here where the misnomer is that sugar is not good
for you so that shouldn't be restricted in any way and actually people need
glucose and they need fructose etc etc not just for thyroid support but you
know your body to run and operate properly and for your you know your
brain function and tissue repair etc it all costs energy and the energy is all
derived from ATP what should be in an efficient way so I wanted to look at
things like there were other kind of sub headings in terms of holistic
treatment to cancer which I think I totally agree with I think that was the
one the main takeaways was the sugar thing but the whole concept of the
hypothalamic pituitary axis that the stress hormone production of cortisol
and the dysregulation of the immune system that can happen through it so in
terms of thyroid support do you do you think it's a kind of given in terms of
somebody dealing with cancer especially if it's metastatic cancer and they're
dealing with it on many fronts and or you know they're in a kind of catch
exit state if not losing losing weight anyway but I'm losing energy that the
thyroid would be affected in that yeah the lack of thyroid is a catabolic
metabolism thyroid is our basic anabolic hormone and so the lower your thyroid
function is the less efficient your metabolism is and that means producing
lactic acid instead of carbon dioxide and so the more stressed or the more
hypothyroid a person is the higher their ratio of lactate to carbon dioxide will
be and the one of the ways that can't that lactic acid promotes cancer growth
is that it shifts the oxidative balance towards reduction away from oxidation
just by the fact that it's an electron donor and the same applies to one of the
so-called ketone bodies beta hydroxy butyrate the hydroxy means it's an
alcohol rather than the ketone and it's made in one of the so-called ketone
bodies that promotes cancer growth by shifting the balance of oxygen the same
way lactic acid does that the pure ketone diet would use acetone instead of
beta hydroxy butyrate okay interesting now you mentioned that was one of the
going to be one of my kind of second the third or fourth point rather the redox
balance but let me quickly just prior to that go to the fact I was very happy to
hear this person talk about the cancer promoting effects of estrogen that was
quite a positive thing and so again you know from an alternative medicine
perspective this was totally correct and again you have substantiated the use of
progesterone in cancers to combat that estrogen rather than per se using a
rheumatase inhibitors or other you know tamoxifen etc other other anti
estrogen compounds what do you think about just speak a little bit to
progesterone and then I'd like to ask you a question about the phytoestrogens in
terms of blocking estrogen what do you think about that but let's start with
progesterone's effect there are lots of anti-inflammatory things that can be in
the absence of the strong estrogens that they can demonstrate binding to the
estrogen receptors and can even cause enlargement of the uterus in large
amounts but if the animal or person already has too much estradiol the
powerful estrogen these things the slight estrogenic activity functions as an
antagonist to the powerful estrogen and so what turns out to dominate is their
anti-inflammatory effect and in in general anti-inflammatory things are
anti-estrogenic okay so you see a kind of limited a limited use for the quote
unquote phytoestrogens because in the presence of regular estradiol they're
not really going to they're not going to matter yes there are other actions that
can be beneficial without regard to how they affect the estrogen so how about
progesterone is an antagonist yeah it definitely prevents the actions of
cortisol and all of the stress hormones promote to cancer metabolism and so at
many levels the progesterone is shifting the metabolism in the right direction
especially by turning off aromatase and there are about half a dozen other very
potent regulators of estrogen production that be sulfatase and sulfur
transferase of glucuronidase and glucuronide transferase for example and
the enzymes that shift the redox state of the estrogen type steroids so you've
got roughly ten ways that progesterone suppresses estrogen production and
metabolism okay well let's just move on a little bit then to what you've touched
on with the redox reaction redox balancing and kind of the effects of
stress basically I think is unequivocal produce and liberate a lot of free
radicals and free radicals cause a lot of tissue damage so the flavonoids this
was also mentioned and we mentioned quercetin recently well in the last few
months in the continuing dialogue about this crazy coronavirus situation and
that the flavonoid quercetin has been used very successfully by Dr. Vladimir
Zelenko amongst several other good doctors in this country to treat COVID
prophylactically in the presence of zinc and talking about the flavonoids being a
chaperone for the zinc to get it into the cells and thereby have its RNA
dependent or RNA polymerase blocking activity as an antiviral now I know you
maybe not don't agree with that in those terms but in terms of a flavonoid and
its anti free radical activities antioxidant activity what about things
like the many flavonoids that there are in the in the plant world yeah I talked
a lot about orange juice because it has fewer drawbacks than many other fruit
sources but I think their name was Johanna Brandt a South American doctor
South South African doctor about oh six years 70 years ago wrote about her use
of a pure grape diet to treat cancer and it didn't sound rational to the
profession so she was just ignored and ridiculed but our grapes certain
varieties of grapes have extremely rich flavonoid and related compounds that are
anti-inflammatory so that combination of anti-inflammatory flavonoids and rich
very high content of glucose made it possible plausible to see the results
that she claimed she got now presumably these would be the red grapes rather
than green no red and blue I think yeah yeah and you remember Dr. Peat what the
varieties were I think comfort was one that she used a lot what about musket
musket come into it I think they must be good they taste so good okay you're
listening to Ask Your Herb Doctor Garverville 91.1 FM from from now it's
732 from now until 8 o'clock you invited to call in with questions 707 923
911 I think I am Sarah Johansson Murray we have Dr. Ray Peat joining us here
okay I think we have a caller Jimmy caller you're on the air my name is
Michael I'm from Redway okay and I'm really interested in the the mitochondrial
redox issues what is your opinion on niacinamide mononucleotide taken as a
supplement in order to increase NADPH concentration and its effects on
serotonin production and I think risk ferritol is also related to that I'm
glad you brought up that because NADH is one of those substances along with coq10
that we want to get into in a little bit so Dr. Peatyeah niacin itself niacin
amide definitely shifts your balance in the right direction towards oxidation
okay good okay so niacin amides certainly on the cards there for redox
balancing so we've gone through you mentioned dark grapes and Concord being
one of those particularly and they mentioned also like I said for the other
flavonoids in terms of free radical quenching and redox balancing as it
were Hesperidin which is another compound similar to quercetin and then
resveratrol and you mentioned that Michael yeah resveratrol as another
powerful antioxidant as well as substances like selenium zinc and coq10
they'd all be well in well advised supplement with those how about things
like what do you think of the immune surveillance side of cancer and whilst
if we knew what it was all about we probably wouldn't have cancer but we
still get it but in terms of the body's inability to really see cancer cell for
what it is and and kill it with macrophages or you know unloading on it
with other substances or many other ways that we can do these things to be in
constant touch with healthy and unhealthy situations what do you think
about immune surveillance I think the mast cells mostly histamine are the
problem that keeps the immune system from going ahead and getting rid of the
cancer these particular pro inflammatory things are driving cancer and
disrupting the immune function so that some of the antibodies formed in
reaction to the abnormal tissue in the cancer some of the antibodies
specifically block other immune reactions and promote the tumor growth
so antihistamines and other compounds that that would stop mast cell
degranulation to release and liberate history would also be useful yeah yeah
definitely and if you mention taking aspirin and antihistamines for cancer
until just recently everyone would really show the idea but now there's
enough foundation for it you can see tremendous improvement just in a couple
days with good antihistamines and aspirin good let's hold it there I want
to ask you more questions about aspirin when we get back from this corner but
we've got a caller on the air so you're on the air call away from what's your
question yes this is I'm in Hawaii and my question is about effects during a
surgery two years ago my husband had an aggressive surgery to remove a large
tumor in his colon and during the five weeks in the hospital he was given
fentanyl for four weeks and then total anesthesia three times and also a
capscan in an MRI after coming home 80% of the time he experiences various
degrees of heaviness in his body his arms legs chest and mouth feel like
they're full of cottony lead and during these times he also feels partially
anesthetized as if observing his body but not quite in it 20% of the time his
energies up he's present and normal although the the cottony mouth never
goes away so also several times a day electric like shocks that last one
second pass through various parts of his body leaving an itch that he scratches
for 10 to 15 minutes to relieve so to us this appears to be lingering damage
from the fentanyl and the anesthesia residue he feels as if his body is
poisoned do you know of anything that might help this situation fentanyl
that's an opioid yeah yeah I would guess short short use of naloxone or naltrexone
might break the cycle one of the effects of morphine or most of the
opioids is to activate inflammatory especially histamine pathways and the
histamine keeps the opioid effect going and just a short one or two or three
days dosing of naloxone or naltrexone can break that cycle by stopping the
morphine or in an orphan effect but make sure that if you're going to ask your
doctor that you request low-dose now naloxone or naltrexone not the normal
dose and normal dose is 50 milligrams so you need something more between 2 and 5
milligrams and if it's working you can tell after the first few milligrams it
can break the cycle in just one day but sometimes two or three days is okay oh
and how do you spell the two words so that I'm sure to say them correctly to
the doctor n-a-l-o-x-o-n-e or n-a-l-t-r-e-x-o-n-e okay and is it given it
through orally or intravenously orally orally okay and in fact Dr. Peatyou
recommend that for anyone who's ever used any opiate medication one to five
days use of low-dose naltrexone to reset the endogenous opiates our body
produces after we come off any type of pain medication that contains opiate
yeah there are numerous types of endogenous opiates or endorphins
experimenters have shown that a particular balance the left side of the
body and the right side of the body use different endorphins for suppression
against injury and there are some people who are developing cancer for example
will have all of their symptoms on one side of the body because of the
predominant type of endorphin they're producing I see and for the anesthesia
is it possible to chelate out or detox the system from the residue of that I've
read that Magnolia bark good nutrition and getting the thyroid activity to an
ideal condition so you're lowering the systemic lactic acid the thyroid reduces
lactic acid production in favor of carbon dioxide and lactic acid is the
main thing that drives endorphin production so to keep the endorphins
down it's important to have to write steroid hormones but especially thyroid
hormone oh all right oh thank you thank you for your call call that's uh thank
you yeah appreciate it okay so 9 2 3 or 7 0 7 first area code 7 0 7 9 2 3 3 9 1 1
Dr. Peat you were just starting to talk about aspirin and that was one of my
next questions in terms of the abundance of information in the alternative world
or exactly well not the not the alternative world that decries aspirin
as some bleeding promoter but the papers that have been done on acetyl salicylic
acid as an anti-cancer substance what do you what do you think about aspirin and
what do you what do you say to it it activates mitochondrial respiration so
it's like an adgent to thyroid hormone okay what what do you what do you think
would be a useful dose for somebody in terms of taking aspirin and then
obviously mitigating any quote-unquote potential to cause any hemodynamic
instability with vitamin K what have you I think it's a good idea just to make
sure you're well charged with vitamin K anywhere from 1 milligram to 30 or 40
milligram is safe if it doesn't contain bad additives the MCT can disturb the
digestive system enough to make it better to use the any sort of vitamin K
that doesn't contain that particular fat and I know several people that are
personally are taking in excess of two grams a day and have done for months and
if not I think maybe up to two years yeah 500 milligrams at a time every
three hours is fine okay so you think that's an effective anti-cancer to 500
milligrams which is about less than two tablets yeah I don't think it hurts to
take 650 at a time but you can tell when the effects are wearing off after three
or four hours taking another one will keep the progress continuing in the
right direction so it's safe is and it's safe and effective as long as you're
taking the vitamin K to at the same time yeah the vitamin K stays in your body
for usually a few weeks even after you're blocking its actions but it's
good to take some every week or so can we talk about how many milligrams of
vitamin K to people might need to take if they're using two aspirin tablets
several times a day one milligram is a pretty good dose of vitamin K but it's
okay to take 20 or 30 milligrams it tends to lower blood pressure so that's
the only thing that's interesting because thorn research thorn with a knee
they've been around for quite some time and we've always gotten our own vitamin
K to from them and they always had it probably about a year ago or so I think
they changed the labeling for supplement fact panel or maybe two years ago but it
was always a one milligram per drop and it's not cheap it's pretty expensive
stuff but then I just saw recently they've read not rebranded but they've
relabeled you know their range and it's kind of in keeping with this nude look
or design or whatever it is they want to achieve with it but the products are
good but they've got a 10 milligram dose so that's that's to say that they are on
their supplement facts panel label for vitamin K to one drop one milligram and
they put the supplement fact panel dose of 10 milligrams as a single dose yeah I
think that's okay because it has side effects of decalcifying your arteries
and some studies showed an anti-cancer effect and the brain protected effect I
thought you'd I thought you'd also said some point in the past about hepatitis
treatment with vitamin K that was yeah anti-inflammatory okay all right so I
think we have another call one year actually I was looking at our log and
we're either supposed to play the music junkie asking us to donate to came in or
you could ad lib one well go ahead and play one I don't want to spoil the oh oh
well I didn't pull it up I thought it would be much better just okay good
good because the listeners who are listening now love Dr. Peat and love your
show yeah that's good to know your preference well there you go look as
always the radio show is not fully funded it's not government control per
se it still relies heavily on community funding and has been since it's an
inception being a community funded radio station now as you well hear and
understand that many many different programs that are on this show are not
things that you're going to hear elsewhere it's a little bit like the
alternative radio show of the alternative world and so public opinions
and viewpoints and expression is First Amendment right that we have a free
speech it's a First Amendment right that we get all sides of the argument not
just one which is the echo chamber we're all living in now folks especially with
Covid and if you don't exercise your rights they don't exist if you don't
exercise them and don't exist and don't lay down man because I tell you they'll
run you over as quick as quick as that so people please donate to came out
whatever you can afford whether it's $10 or 20 or 50 or whatever just get your
money send it to came out it'll be used to keep the show going to power the
lights to keep the engineers on keep the upkeep and we don't get paid well I know
you don't I know you get paid your volunteers you do it because you love it
well no you don't need to give money to keep us on you need to give money so
that the board will work so that I can use it to keep you on yes okay so please
not the board of people but yeah thank you very much to the board and if you
really want to step up and help came out in a way other than volunteering in the
studio and you have like say treasurer skills or something consider at least
like going to the board meetings on zoom and getting up to speed on stuff and
then consider being a board member at some point in the future okay well thank
you that's that and then let's carry on with the last 10 minutes or so so people
if you're in the area you want to call him questions 707 923 3911 Dr. Raymond
Peat giving his professional advice or advice call it opinion say advice will
make you do anything but it's a free world and you have alternatives if you
want to use them folks so don't be afraid of it at the end of the day we
mentioned those things about the dark pigments and then immune surveillance
you talked about the mast cells degranulating and histamine being
liberated is all being very anti so rather inflammatory and not what you
want is the antithesis of what you want the next thing I wanted to bring up was
the concept of invasion of local tissues now cancers obviously do this so they do
it quite well because apart from I think breaking down connective tissue which
they can do with various enzymes and hyaluronic acid and stuff they are pretty
good at mobilizing themselves and getting into circulation because of
their effects on the vasculature what do you think about substances that would
improve the endothelia make it more resilient if that's possible as a word
what do you think about the metastatic ability of cancer and how we would hope
to contain a cancer if it was growing so that we could treat it before it has had
a chance to spread keeping the HIF down I think is the main thing it promotes
metastasis and damage to the surrounding tissues we've got two people on the air
I don't want to cut you off but I know you like answering people and I'd love
to hear you your side of the discussion so we've got two people on the air
first caller you're on the air where you from what's your question yes you're on
the air what are you from what's your question my name is Bruce and I'm from
Wendy gap near Garberville hey Bruce what's your question I have a question
what's a normal blood sugar historically I mean and isn't a high blood sugar an
inflammation for our venous system I've been a diabetic six shots a day for 43
years and I've studied this somewhat on my own in my situation I'm trying to
avoid sugar and to keep my blood sugar low because the effect of a high blood
sugar seems to be destructive yeah so I'm curious what the doctor thinks about a
normal blood sugar level inflammation good if you look at the healthiest
pregnancies they used to be in the diabetic range 140 milligrams percent of
glucose and the diabetes industry does lots of experiments supposedly showing
that high glucose is toxic but what they're doing is creating a diabetic
type of high glucose meaning that the cells are unable to get and use the
glucose so all of the studies that I've seen in the dangers of elevated glucose
were actually studies blocking the ability to use glucose so that it would
rise so I understand that insulin is necessary to get the sugar out of your
blood and I guess into your fat bank is basically where it goes and so with the
high blood sugar in my case I can't get my fat back because insulin also holds
fat on your body so the idea was to come down in blood sugar and then insulin
would come down with it and then let the fat come from your fat bank and be
metabolized and maintain a weight a better weight so I've managed to get
pretty thin over the years because I've worked hard to keep my blood sugar down
and I don't eat a lot of carbohydrates but I'm really curious about recommending
that people have a high blood sugar is that what's happened to people or do
normal people keep a low blood sugar even though they're eating a lot of
glucose yeah if you're able to keep your cortisol at another stress hormones low
but that's what lets your tissues use the glucose so you can turn off the
liver's gluconeogenesis and stop pushing your blood sugar up to overcome
the inability to oxidize it I understand the gluconeogenesis but that that
doesn't happen in my understanding until blood sugar comes down your liver's
inactive when you have a high ramping up and down blood sugar you're not doing
new code gluconeogenesis but when it gets down to our whatever familiar
standpoint and I think it's in the 80s then the liver begins to do gluconeogenesis
to provide sugar for our brain which of course constantly needs it I think
the crucial regulatory factors thyroid hormone that activates the oxidation
system and makes the insulin unnecessary okay all this time I've been taking a
thyroid supplement because I'm familiar low in thyroid so I also take a thyroid
supplement have you checked your body temperature yeah constantly when you go
around in society these days you might get your body temperature tested at the
dentist office and I'm usually a little low than 97 something usually yeah do
you've heard about exercise reducing your need for insulin certainly it's the
same thing with thyroid hormone warming you up the same way exercise does and
activating your ability to oxidize glucose partly just by being warmer I
hear you I know cold is probably good for that way to be a little chilly how
about one more question what do you think about actually we've got another
caller after you and we're at the top of the air and I asked you to be quick so
sorry we're just gonna go to the next caller okay let's take this next caller
quickly what's your question where you from hello hello you're on the air
what's your question where you from oh I'm from Artea and I have a question I
have grandchildren who love to have lots of burgers yeast when I make them popcorn
is it bad for them to have too much one is the boy and one is the girl nine and
five and so I went with their breweries you know I'll take this s on the air okay
Dr. Peat did you hear that not very well what was she saying about I didn't
catch you she's talking about brewer's yeast I think he actually wanted to know if it's
good to feed kids brewer's yeast but that might not be exactly it are you still there
fine yeah okay Dr. Peat what do you think a brew is east there's a source of
B vitamins and brewer's yeast oh it's so high in phosphate you have to be
sure to get milk or cheese calcium supplement and vitamin D with it if you
use it every day in any significant quantity you'll fairly quickly notice
depressed calcium metabolism okay well we probably better hold you there too
Dr. Peat just so I can give out people give people your information thanks so
much for joining us okay thank you Dr. Peat for joining us and thank you for
answering that gentleman's question regarding sugar and diabetes and I
wanted to say one thing quickly if that gentleman is still listening if you
email us we'll send you a chart so you can check your temperature and pulses and
compare them to what a normal temperature and pulse would both levels
be before and after eating and you can compare to what it would be normally if
you had your thyroid level optimal so please email us Sarah or Andrew at
Western Botanical Medicine and we'll send you that chart so you can test
yourself okay well thank you for that Sarah so let's give out Dr. Peat's
information so people have listened to that show and we're gonna listen to it
on the archive Dr. Raymond Peat has a wealth of knowledge and archive material
on his website www.raypeat.com we can be reached through our website
westernbotanicalmedicine.com my wife and I are both naturopathic doctors we
produce a range of extracts of medicinal plants we graduated in 1999 and 2001 so
we've been doing this 20 plus years now and Dr. Peat has been a guiding light
for the last 11 at least so until the third Friday of next month I think we
could probably carry on wrapping up this month's cancer dialogues but thanks for
those people that called in and yeah we'll be on wintertime next month so
it's all of you happy for enjoy the colors and the coming rain we'll speak
to you then good night thank you for listening my name is Sarah Johannesen
Murray my name is Andrew Murray thank you good night
and this has been Redwood Community Radio KMUD Garberville KMUE Eureka
KLAI Laytonville just a moment and you will be stepping out on a wing and a
prayer with Shaka and Shyla thanks for tuning in
[Music]